Oh
[Music]
Jurnee
brews that I'm better than bloody it's
been a long time since I've shaved with
a normal razor and it takes a little
practice sorry about that I got to keep
dabbing this blood sides apologize first
tardiness
you couldn't find where I put his socks
this morning lots changed in the nearly
eight years that I have been here let me
just say a couple of things first of all
the obvious I want to state and I know I
speak for Patty and Amy and Annie and
obviously for me we want to express our
most profound and everlasting gratitude
to President Trump how do you properly
thank someone who's given you back the
freedom that was stolen from you he
didn't have to do this he's a Republican
president I was a Democratic governor
and doing this there's nothing to help
his politics President Trump is a man
who is tough and outspoken but he also
has a kind heart and this is an act of
kindness and I also believe it's the
beginning of the process to to actually
turn an injustice into a justice sorry
about this blood
all these years away I never stopped
reminding myself of the words from a
poem it's called the gate of the year go
out into the darkness and put your hand
into the hand of God that shall be to
you better than light and safer than a
known way it's been a long time since
I've been home nearly eight years nearly
3,000 days I suppose a better way to
measure how long it's been is to our
daughters a me and Annie when I left
home so long ago Amy our older daughter
was a sophomore in high school and it'll
be two years this spring since she's
graduated from college and now just
recently Amy earned a master's degree
and we're very proud of you sweetheart
and Annie our younger daughter was 8
years old when I left she was about this
high
now she's 16 and now she has her
driver's license and she's doing good in
school
and she plays the piano and we're very
proud of her too look at you sweetheart
look at you my baby's growing up so fast
again on behalf of my family we want to
express our profound his gratitude to
President Trump it's been a long unhappy
journeys he's have been hard years for
our children they've been hard years for
Patti and for me I spent my first 32
months in prison nearly three years
behind what the inmates called a razor
wire the barbed wire fence you can't go
near that fence if you do there are
prison guards there armed with machine
guns who have the discretion to shoot
you I didn't go near that fence
the buildings behind that fence where
the inmates live in sleep are squalid
places they're cold and dark like tombs
they were about nine hundred inmates
they're drug dealers cartel members
gangbangers bank robbers that were men
they were committed murder con artists a
lot of sex offenders about two percent
of the population when the so called
white-collar category for most of my
time there my home was a six foot by 12
foot a six foot by eight foot prison
cell with four cement walls a big heavy
iron door that can shut you in a small
window with bars on it and a bunk bed I
slept on the top bunk often late at
night I would look through that window
and pass those bars out into the night
sky
and I think of home I think of my
children I think of Patti sometimes
sometimes I could almost feel her near
me I was I would say to myself one day
one day I'll make it back to you and
hold your hand sweetheart and I would
remember what a gracious thing it's been
to walk through life with you yeah
anyway so I'm again on behalf of Patti
and Amy and Annie and me we want to
again express our our deepest gratitude
the President Trump like I said as a
Republican president and a Democratic
governor he didn't have to do this but
President Trump is not a typical
politicians right he's tough he's
outspoken he gets things done he's a
problem solver in a business where too
many politicians don't want to solve
problems all they want to do is play
politics and get nothing done for the
people
he's got a I'm a trumpet crap the
trouble presents right if I have ability
to vote for him well I don't know that
I'd allow me to vote but her but I'll
get into that in a minute but let me
just say that our president is uh he's
tough and outspoken and he has the
courage to challenge the old way he's
the one who's actually fighting to bring
real change that's why he gets so much
pushback but now we're standing being
tough he's also a man with a kind heart
he sees wrong and he tries to ride it
just like he did in the case of Alice
Marie Johnson you know who she is the
grandmother from Alabama who served 21
years in prison on a life sentence as a
first-time nonviolent drug offender a
life sentence as a first-time nonviolent
drug offender Alice Marie Johnson's case
is probably one of the better
illustrations that shows how the federal
criminal justice system
disproportionally discriminates against
african-americans and people of color
and how the 1994 crime bill has led to
the over sentencing and to the creation
of what the author Michelle Alexander
has called the new Jim Crow in America
don't know what I'm talking about right
dr. Clinton's 1994 crime bill passed by
my fellow Democrats before I got to
Congress fortunately as soon as
president Trump learned of the injustice
against Alice Murray he immediately put
a stop to it and he sent her home to her
family and fortunately because this is a
president who gets things done through
his leadership and with the help of
organizations like cut 50 president
Trump was able to build a necessary
bipartisan support to pass the historic
first step back a new law that begins
the process of reforming a broken
criminal justice system and putting it
in to the racist injustice caused by
that racist 1994 crime bill now ask for
me obviously I've got 10,000 reasons to
be thankful to president Trump I'm
obviously thankful to be home to have my
freedom back to just be able to hold my
wife's hand but most of all I'm thankful
to you mr. president for giving my
daughters their father back
my daughters are growing up and the day
is not too far off when they will go out
into the world on their own now I wish I
could slow down time but no matter where
their life's journey may lead they will
always take with them the realization
that the kindest gift they've ever
received in their lives came from you
Thank You mr. president for what you've
done for me but better far far better
thank you for what you've done for them
I'd like to thank a few people real
quick I'd like to thank my old friend
the Reverend Jesse Jackson for his voice
and for his help and for his support I
want to thank my friend and former
colleague in the Congress congressman
Jesse Jackson jr. for his friendship and
his support I want to thank Patty's dad
for alderman Mel Richard Mel for his
love and support to our daughters and to
his daughter patty I want to thank this
mystery man a young man who brought all
this about I just met him yesterday and
this is Mark Vargas he's quite a guy and
he's he's the kind of guy who can get
you out of prison if you find yourself
stuck there and I'm really grateful to
his efforts and what he's done on my
behalf sorry
sorry yeah one second my friend the
Scriptures teach us and history shows
that in the long run right defeated will
in the end overcome history the
Scriptures teaches the history shows
that in the long run right defeated will
in the end overcome wrong triumphant and
as dr. Martin Luther King used to say
truth crushed to earth will one day rise
again because no lie can live forever
I'm returning home today from a long
exile
a freed political prisoner I want to say
again to the people of Illinois who
twice elected me governor I didn't let
you down I would have let you down if I
gave into this but resistance to tyrants
is but his obedience to God not long ago
United States Supreme Court Justice
Stephen Breyer warned about this he
warned about federal prosecutors
bringing criminal charges against
government officials for what he
described as routine practices Justice
Breyer went on to point out and I'm
quoting him to give that kind of power
to a criminal prosecutor who is
virtually uncontrollable is dangerous to
our separation of powers and quote I
learned the hard way just how dangerous
that is from beginning to end this was
persecution masquerading his prosecution
I got into politics to help people I
didn't get into politics to make money I
didn't get an apology to rich my family
or my friends I got into politics
because I was fortunate to live in the
greatest country that's ever existed my
immigrant father fought the Nazis he
spent four years in a prisoner of war
camp after that war II spent three years
in a refugee camp waiting for the day
that one day the Congress that one day
his youngest son would become a member
of will passed a law called the
displaced persons Act to allow him and
millions of others like him immigrants
from all around the world with long and
hard to pronounce last names to be able
to come to America to pursue freedom and
opportunity my dad basically did about
seven years in prison I got him beat
I've done almost eight but my dad
believed in America he took the gift of
freedom not for granted because he knew
what it was like to live under
oppression
he didn't go back to his country
Yugoslavia because it was a communist
country where freedom wasn't allowed so
he came here and he got a job working in
a factory and for most of his life all
of his life in the United States my dad
was a working man a factory worker and
my mother was a working mother who
worked for the Chicago Transit Authority
passing out the transfers at the subway
stations they never had a chance to live
the American dream and older owned a
home of their own but they worked hard
and sacrificed so that their kids can
have opportunities they didn't have this
is the American story and my mother and
father lived that and so I'd like to
think that as governor what I did was to
try to draw in my own life experience
and try to take those experiences and
turn them into something real to help
people that's why we provided health
care to all the kids in Illinois through
the all kids program because I saw as a
young child a cousin passed away from
leukemia at the age of 12 and didn't
have insurance and his mother and father
lost what little they had we provided
free transportation every one of our
senior citizens are they disabled
because I remember my father as a senior
citizen being part of a senior citizen
discount card he had where he could take
the bus for half the price and we were
able to take that and apply that to
everybody in the state of Illinois I
wouldn't allow that swamp in Springfield
and my fellow Democrats down there who
just wanted to raise taxes on the
working people to raise their taxes and
so it was always a struggle a constant
battle to try to remember who I was
supposed to fight for and so I hope now
looking to the future that I can draw
from my life experience particularly
those over the last eight years in
prison and eleven years since this all
came to us and do something to try to
fight to help people who've been
wrongfully incarcerated or those and
this is probably the rule and not the
exception those who have been over
sentenced nonviolent offenders who made
a mistake did wrong but have been
sentenced that years in prison that not
only destroy their lives and steal from
them their futures but they hurt their
children their family I saw what they do
to families because I saw it happen in
my own and every time I go into the
visiting room to visit
my family I'd look around that room and
I'd see mothers with their children and
you can tell it was a mother because you
can see it in the sadness of her face I
would see father's with their young
children and you can see the the
discomfort that the family feels so I
hope that as I move forward I can take
some of that experience that I've had
and try to do what I can to try to
improve what is a broken and I believe
in many cases a corrupt criminal justice
system when it comes to crime and
punishment in America the United States
and carcere rates six to ten times more
people than any other industrialized
nation in the world we put more people
in jail than China and Russia
federal prosecutors like to boast about
their 97 percent conviction rate but
doesn't that both show just how rigged
the system is unless you're the
undefeated boxing champion Floyd money
Mayweather who else ever wins 97 percent
of the time at anything for money
Mayweather has not been defeated
don't say that daddy you probably get a
phone call from everyday people every
day people who who find themselves
caught up in the system have no chance
and they many of them recognize the
futility in fighting for their rights so
they just give in and under duress
because they're being threatened with
long sentences they agree to plead
guilty to things they didn't do unfair
unfair and cruel over sentencing is the
rule it's not the exception equal
protection under the law doesn't exist
wildly unfair disparities in sentencing
for the same or similar offenses are not
uncommon and defy common sense and in
way too many cases way too many
nonviolent offenders are given way
longer prison sentences than violent
offenders and sex offenders who've
actually caused great physical and
emotional harm to their victims it is a
broken criminal justice system and it
has been for a long time and it's a
racist criminal justice system but
there's hope and one of the great
ironies of history is that so far up
till now in the history our country no
one has done more or it's currently
working to do more to fix this broken
and races criminal justice system
president trunk and jarred cushions
right one last thing I'm gonna dab this
blood again am I good all right I just
feel them on me I'd like to say one
thing about I'd like to say something
about diversity yeah and I'd like to
direct my remarks to all of my fellow
underdogs out there who find themselves
up against powerful forces and long odds
to anyone facing hard circumstances
who've suffered loss I hurt him or who
like me I've hit rock bottom you may be
down all your hope may seem to have
disappeared the road you have to travel
is a long one at home that's where you
want to be it's so far away you can't
even see the flicker of a light at the
end of the tunnel but don't give up
don't give up think of the people you
love
I'll get it out hang on think of the
people you love that's where you'll find
your purpose
my love for my family and my faith in
God is what sustained me during this
long and seemingly never-ending trial it
gave me purpose to stay strong and along
with Patti to try to set the right
example for our daughters to show them
that when adversity enters your life
even when your calamity comes on like a
whirlwind and just about everything just
about everything has been taken away
from you and your hearts broken don't
quit fight fight keep fighting and
persevere in storms and through the dark
passages and when you find yourself
alone all alone in the lonely wilderness
because it is there in that lonely
wilderness where we are tried and tested
that we must rise to our circumstances
we must rise above our circumstances and
dare to dream it is not an ending but a
beginning or out of weakness we are made
strong every mile I ran every push up I
did every book I read every word I wrote
was my way of fighting back my way of
using the time in the wilderness to
prepare for a better day waiting in the
shadows waiting for justice
waiting and hoping so living faith hope
and love the vehicle and fate yes baron
de amor and if you have to take a stand
and don't be afraid you're not alone you
never go alone it is so often the case
that in the sadness of life we look for
God my faith in Him
turn despair into hope it made me strong
trusting that one day through the grace
of God he will turn darkness into light
and lead me home thank you okay here's
my room it's actually quite amazing
who like fake game of Firehouse Subs at
the Air Force Base most people by the
way could not have been more nice and
accommodating and helpful and upbeat and
really really were amazing